and tonight more evidence of the biden
open borders agenda and preferential
treatment for illegal immigrants because
our very own lawrence jones lj has
exclusive footage of biden's secret
migrant flights from this week right in
new york where illegals have flown into
obscure airports and driven and dropped
off in undisclosed locations at all
hours of the night or early morning
flights as jen calls them anyway uh
cross country host lawrence jones joins
us now to explain more lj uh this is a
big deal
yes
you almost got arrested i heard good job
i would have bailed you out by the way i
would have come up with the money listen
i know you got a lot of money sean so i
i think i was just fine okay uh listen
listen wait you know what you know what
because of that comment i'm gonna leave
you in jail next time that's it
thank god we have no bail laws anyway
you're right i'll go i come and work for
you this is what i get uh so sean you
know the bite administration had told us
that these flights were going to end
that this wasn't going on we got a tip
uh from a source saying that they were
doing these flights yet again they had
quit them for a moment but we did
something different you know they get on
these buses about three buses there
about 150 plus migrants that got onto
those buses women children
grown men we decided to follow one of
those buses
and
this is one of the term bikes in new
jersey all these cars that you're seeing
right there were waiting for the
migrants well i wanted to go up there
and talk to them and see where exactly
did they come from and where were they
going so as i began to do that i guess
it agitated some of the they started
flashing our cameramen
with lights and everything and trying to
conceal their identity and as you see
under the bus there's all this luggage
and all this well eventually they just
stopped they didn't want to get out of
the car because they knew my camera was
out there
and so they eventually the migrants the
people that are here illegally called
the police on me and things got a little
contentious sean
you can't make this up and they get a
police escort on top of it all too
well
they said that it was harassment i
explained to the officers that i was
just doing my job but if you want to see
all the footage it'll be on my show 10
p.m eastern time start being nicer to me
i'll bail you out again you know next
time you get in trouble give me a call i
won't even call your mom and dad i won't
write you out i won't tell i won't tell
anybody i'll tell you this i may have
dropped your name when i was being close
i won't confirm or deny it here it is
another attack against hannity here the
cops will be here tomorrow
all right lj uh don't forget lj's new
hit show cross country every saturday
night at 10 o'clock right here on fox
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else